dans cette langue le masculin fait le
neutre on n'a pas besoin d'y rajouter
des points au milieu des mots ou des
tiréss ou des choses pour la rendre
visible c'est pour cela aussi qu'il faut
permettre à cette langue de vivre de
s'inspirer des autres de voler des mots
y compris à l'autre bout du monde j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure de continuer à
inventer mais d'en garder aussi les
fondements les socles de sa grandammère
la force de sa syntaxe et de ne pas
céder aux air du temp dans cette langue
le masculin fait le neutre on n pas
besoin d'y rajouter des points au milieu
des mots ou des tirés ou des choses pour
la rendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
visible